I think one of the reasons that we
started tournelle design was we wanted
to promote a different type of building
we wanted to create homes that were
widely accessible but that didn't
sacrifice design or quality in the
process of being delivered via systems
there are several advantages to building
a prefab home there's a predictability
of quality and of time and a cost that
allows us to put together a highly
flexible building virtually anywhere in
a relatively short period of time but
there also a number of environmental
benefits when you're building something
in a factory environment you are using a
local labor pool that has to travel a
limited distance you are reducing waste
you are cutting a board for one job and
using the rest of it on another job so
you can have all sorts of controls in
place which make it more environmentally
friendly
[Music]
what we're hoping to achieve with this
home is to challenge ourselves to use
new products and test them in a way that
allows us to create new standards that
we can then apply to our future clients
this is the first home that we've done
that's comprised completely of
engineered wood products what it means
is that we're using wood and wood
byproducts that would otherwise go to
waste or be turned into paper and we're
making a home out of it it has a very
small footprint different attributes the
home quite literally transformed to
allow it to live larger
it's also the first time that we're
creating a completely fossil fuel free
site the house runs on photovoltaic
electricity that's generated here we
never need to buy fossil fuels again the
floors are a concrete which provides a
thermal mass which helps keep the
building warm in the winter and keeps it
cool and summer the area of the great
room is shaded by the solar panels and
the rest of the roof is reflective we
sized the overhangs to ensure that we
don't get any direct sunlight on the
windows during the overheated period
thereby reducing the amount of air
conditioning that we need to use in the
home
we're trying to exhibit in the house
that the combination of all of these
things can feel very much like high
quality home doesn't have to feel like
an experiment I think my time at MIT
provided me with the confidence to
always search for another solution you
keep pushing because you know there has
to be a better wedding we started the
practice predicated on a belief that
there is a better way to design and
build and deliver homes for people to
live in it's a different kind of
practice model it's great to be involved
in that we are interrogating it
improving it and iterating on it
constantly
I think it's born out of a method of
problem solving that was grown at MIT